[Música]
bienvenidos al momento de medio ambiente
en france 24 yo soy maría clara calle y
hoy hablaremos de la amazonía y es que
en la cumbre climática con 26 más de 100
países prometieron frenar la
deforestación para el año 2030 y aunque
no sólo los árboles amazónicos son los
que se talan todos los años si es uno de
los lugares más importantes para
preservar y es que este es el bosque
tropical más grande de todo el mundo y
el último que queda de estas
proporciones además es el que más
absorbe gases de efecto invernadero mide
casi lo mismo que todo eeuu y alcanza
parte de territorio de nueve países
sudamericanos brasil es el que tiene más
parte de la amazonía con el 64% seguido
de perú bolivia colombia y venezuela en
mucha menor medida también hay amazonía
en ecuador surinam guyana y la guyana
francesa
pero este gigante bosque cada vez pierde
más su capacidad para absorber los gases
de efecto invernadero una de las
principales razones de ello es la
deforestación pues entre más talan
árboles en la amazonía menos capacidad
tiene este bioma para combatir el
calentamiento global y casi el 80% de la
deforestación en esta región del mundo
ocurre en brasil lo más preocupante es
que en ese país la tala está disparada a
niveles que no se veían desde hace 15
años veamos más en este reporte
un área de ocho veces el tamaño del gran
londres destruida por la deforestación
los datos de la agencia de investigación
espacial de brasil revelan que la tala
ilegal en la amazonía aumentó en casi un
22% en el último año el nivel más alto
en 15 años entre 2009 y 2014 la amazonía
brasileña tuvo las tasas de
deforestación más bajas jamás
registradas pero los niveles comenzaron
a aumentar nuevamente cuando el
presidente yair bolsonaro asumió el
cargo en 2019 la oposición culpa que el
mandatario ha fomentado las actividades
agrícolas y mineras en términos más
generales las ong y los grupos indígenas
también lo acusan de debilitar las
salvaguardias ambientales en el foro
invertir en brasil que se llevó a cabo
esta semana en dubai por sonar o dijo
que su país ha sido atacado injustamente
en lo que a la selva amazónica se
refiere y afirmó que era demasiado
húmeda para incendiarse
con los ojos los ataques que sufre
brasil cuando se trata de la amazonía no
son justos están allí se conservan más
del 90% de esa área está estrictamente
igual que cuando fue descubierta en 1500
y la amazonía es fantástica a más de una
fantasía
bolsonaro estuvo ausente de la reciente
cumbre climática en glasgow pero en el
evento sus delegados se comprometieron a
detener y revertir la pérdida de bosques
para 2030 los árboles de la amazona se
absorben grandes cantidades de dióxido
de carbono que calentarían aun más el
planeta pero cuando se talan o se queman
ese mismo carbono se libera rápidamente
a la atmósfera y para combatir la
pérdida de este bioma en colombia 5
organizaciones se aliaron el propósito
es que la amazonía sea prioridad para el
próximo presidente que elige el país en
el 2022 la alianza escucha la amazonía
está conformada por la organización
nacional de los pueblos indígenas de la
amazonía
la fundación gaia amazonas la fundación
para la conservación y el desarrollo
sostenible
wwf y greenpeace colombia ellos proponen
estos cuatro puntos para proteger la
amazonía colombiana
pero proteger el bosque frente a
presiones y amenazas es indispensable en
frenar la pérdida de biodiversidad que
existe hoy en día segundo asegurar la
conectividad de los ecosistemas y
preservar la diversidad cultural de la
amazonía sin los servicios ecológicos de
la selva nos quedamos sin agua
y quienes mejor saben proteger esos
servicios ecológicos son los pueblos
indígenas y las comunidades locales que
habitan la región tercero
el pleno reconocimiento de los gobiernos
locales indígenas
la puesta en funcionamiento de las
entidades territoriales indígenas
reconocidas en la constitución es el pie
que nos da para construir un país
verdaderamente diverso y multicultural
aportando lo mejor del conocimiento
indígena y de las soluciones no
indígenas para proteger el amazonas'
para hoy y para el cuarto y último
poner un modelo de desarrollo sostenible
desde y para la amazonía
el modelo que tenemos ha permitido la
deforestación la degradación ambiental y
la pérdida de biodiversidad el modelo ha
fracasado
es hora de un cambio de paradigmas y
esto sólo puede lograrse por medio de un
diálogo amplio e inclusivo con los
pueblos y las comunidades indígenas la
fundación gaia amazonas explica que este
bosque tropical colapsaría si su
deforestación alcanza entre el 20 y el
25 por ciento y el problema es que ahora
está en el 17 por ciento esto genera un
gran impacto porque la amazonía almacena
el 20 por ciento del agua dulce de todo
el mundo y estas aguas están siendo cada
vez más contaminadas así pasa por
ejemplo en perú que como veíamos antes
es el segundo país con más amazonía el
instituto de investigación es dedicado
al bioma amazónico peruano detectó por
primera vez que una especie de pez
conocido como boquichico está ingiriendo
micro plásticos que están en las aguas
el problema es mayor porque este pez es
uno de los que más se venden para el
consumo humano
especialmente en la ciudad amazónica de
iquitos que está rodeada por agua y
tiene al río amazonas justo
el iap del ministerio de ambiente
peruano afirma que los plásticos
imperceptibles al ojo humano son
producto de la mala gestión de los
residuos plásticos esto estaba afectando
a los peces y también podría impactar en
la salud de las personas según afirman
los científicos y así llegamos al final
de nuestro programa vean más información
en france 24 punto com y consulten
nuestro canal de youtube nos vemos
[Música]